Is far infrared soda okay if my kidneys feel like they are struggling a bit? Yes I
think far infrared soda is very okay make sure you drink it lots of water
that's my only thing you don't want to be dehydrated dehydration on your
kidneys is the hardest thing on your kidneys so make sure you're drinking a lot of
water I did OT for two consecutive days and sweat a lot third day felt like my
kidneys were struggling a bit I've been drinking lots of lemon water and
added some trace minerals and electrolytes also can trace minerals and
electrolytes cause kidney issues so I don't know which trace minerals you're
talking about if you're talking about trace minerals that are the liquid trace
minerals throw them away don't use those use the all-beyond trace minerals like
our brand the clear multimin plus are my favorite ones or our clear multimin use
those trace minerals not a liquid trace minerals they can liquid trace
minerals are our elemental minerals meaning like right out of the ground and
you're they don't do well you don't absorb them well and they're hard on your
kidneys so don't be taking those I spoke about the right form of minerals a while
back and you want to be making sure you're taking minerals in the form that they
were created to be consumed in which would be plant-based minerals that has a
double bond amino acid the only ones that you can get that way are they'll say
all-beyond or tracks on the back of the bottle they are not a liquid product they
are a powder product